un recién llegado a la familia de los
dinosaurios con cocananoy que hace parte
de la familia de los adrosaurios era
herbívoro vivía en grupo y gracias a sus
dos poderosas patas traseras era capaz
de alcanzar la vegetación más alta
recorría lo que hoy es chile hace 72
millones de años con quién era
relativamente pequeño de aproximadamente
4 metros de longitud y un peso estimado
en una una tonelada era una de los
saurio relativamente pequeño ya que hay
otros parientes del que podían alcanzar
los 12 hasta 15 metros de longitud esta
nueva especie supone una sorpresa para
los científicos que desconocían la
presencia de este tipo de dinosaurio en
el hemisferio sur Aunque es común en el
hemisferio norte el animal debe su
nombre a su Pico con coquén significa
que parece un Pato Salvaje en
lenguatehuelche la primera población que
habitó la región Esta es la quinta
especie de dinosaurio descubierta en
Chile tres de esos cinco dinosaurios han
sido de una gran importancia científica
porque no se ha encontrado algo parecido
en otras partes del mundo o no con ese
estado de conservación pasaron casi 10
años desde el descubrimiento de los
primeros fósiles hasta la confirmación
por parte de la Universidad de chile y
el Instituto Antártico chileno de Queen
es efectivamente una especie completa